well spring break is next week for the
kiddos and maybe you're looking for
something to do something fun how about
a magic show these are ten dollar
tickets over at The Orleans and Laura
negretti's been there all morning
learning some tricks Lauren if you keep
going you may earn your way into the
Magic Castle
banking on that Nate good morning you
guys yeah that's right where you've been
here at the venue with Adam London
talking about laughter noon so this is
your 10th anniversary doing this show 10
years doing the afternoon yep yeah it's
an interactive show 10 years ten dollars
that's right ten dollars to come and see
the show very interactive so you can
bring your family to the show you bring
your little grandson to the show your
five-year-old all the way to your 95
year old it's very interactive we get
adults up on the stage do magic with we
get little kids up on the stage too so
show runs about an hour and 10 minutes
so come on down check it out yeah we got
a little Abridged version here of the
car trip yeah so we'll do another quick
card trick so uh uh just tell me when to
stop Lauren
stop all right take a look at it okay
take a look at it
I'm going to read your mind okay
that hurts okay seven of diamonds is
that what it was it was
and we didn't pre-set that up before the
show here I'll do it again tell everyone
to stop okay
stop okay take a look at it okay
three of diamonds yes I'm unbelievable
see that's just some of the magic you're
blown yeah and exactly and you know
Sherry wanted a rabbit out of the Hat
you know Sherry I'm sorry it's not
really his style we do something
different around here we do we do stuff
with ducks so Lauren pull the duck off
the tie okay okay nope you gotta start
up here and pull down and then they'll
come up just like what perfect well I'm
sure that's uh you know duck for dinner
that's right yeah a little rubbery so I
don't think you're going to want to eat
it but the Ducks are a huge portion of
the show too so come and check it out
with the rubber duck show Perfect all
right well like you said more details
free on website 8newsnow.com back to you
guys with my rubber duck
rabbits Ducks I'll take whatever we can
get this morning Lauren that's a good
substitute for sure good stuff oh have
fun great show